all right what up guys welcome
to morning coffee thoughts except I've
quit coffee I'm like a week strong you'd
be so proud of me I have a big water jug
I'm eating some eggs
you are gonna I'm gonna be so skinny by
my birthday you wait
you wait you guys won't even know what
to do with me I'm gonna be like
it
anyways before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel also sign up
for my memberships
um the reason the memberships are so
important is because I'm trying to pay
my rent with memberships
um and you're thinking why why do I want
to pay your rent
fair question right I'm getting a bigger
place and I'm nervous because it's it's
bigger it's more expensive but I know
I'm going to use every inch of that
place for content and filming I'm gonna
do
you guys don't even know I'm gonna do
like a dating show I'm gonna do smash or
pass episodes I'm gonna do uh I wanna do
wife school with different girls yeah I
got I got plans but I need this big
space because
with air conditioning because you guys
see the issues we've had
um
foreign
okay so today's topic the types of
archetypes of women
so
I was telling this to to Jess the other
day how it's weird because when you get
bigger you talk to the same person in
different bodies that's the only way I
know how to describe it like
and then
the same types of females but just in
different bodies and you keep talking to
them over and over again
foreign
's individual
and special but
special because I sure beat a lot of you
and you're all the same
so let's start with the baby mamas
there's two types of baby mamas the ones
that
understand they took an l
they understand dating's harder
they're not on government assistance
they're just like you know what I'm a
baby mama I took that l
I know [ __ ] is gonna be harder for me
but there's still a little delusional
as in they still have hope
even when for a lot of them it's over
these baby mamas are usually a bit
better than the second type of baby
Mama's like
that I put it some of them are in the
church they're like reformed but they
still don't think they're a modern woman
because they're like I'm not like those
baby mamas well
well Teresa
you kind of are you are but you aren't
okay
then there's the second type of baby
mamas so the first type at least accepts
that men in general don't want to date
baby mamas their baby trying to Rebrand
themselves a little in the church
they're not out here in the streets like
the other type the other type of baby
mama doesn't give a [ __ ] she doesn't
give two
shits her kid's basically an accessory
if she can be on government assistance
she's on it or
and she makes a lot of money she
probably left the baby daddy because
of the money thing he probably didn't
make enough money so it's the same type
but like one has some of them have money
some don't okay they don't really care
about their kids they act like they care
but
like what are you doing on my podcast
who's watching the kids
anyways you look at their Instagram
their ass is all over it
their ass is all over it
um
it's like booty booty booty booty
rocking everywhere booty booty booty
booty rocket
um clearly edited
because I'll see him on the show I'm
like your butt doesn't look like that
um
these baby mamas
believe that the men that sleep with
them will commit to them
don't get me wrong
that's a common misconception across the
board that's not specific to baby mamas
look it women we confuse sex with love
it's just that's that's not that's not
special the baby mouse okay the next
archetype these are the girls that I'm
most common with that I know I grew up
with
these are the athletes
now we as athletes we're raised a little
bit to be boys
or usually have a lot of hobbies
um because
we are grown up like pushed to be in
everything so if you're an athlete you
weren't pushed just to be an athlete oh
no no no you are pushed to do everything
humanly possible typically it's Ellie
stop it sit
it's like
so
the other archetype of woman it's like
you're involved in athletes you're kind
of awkward you're not super like
hold on guys I'm gonna move my dog
you're annoying me you're annoying me
you're annoying me no you're getting
kicked out of the room
so anyways the next archetype
is the athletes so we're a bit awkward
with the men like we don't and a lot of
us are kind of shy afraid to show
interest
uh because growing up we were just one
of the boys we weren't really
like
and it's funny a lot of us we get friend
zoned but not in the way you guys give
like other girls get friend zoned where
they're getting like slept with you know
no no no no not us we're just one of the
boys we just hang out I think that's
partially why I do so well with red pill
content I'm just like chilling
um
um what else about yeah we're and then
we lack femininity we're usually hard
workers
um but like femininity I would say is
where we struggle okay
because you know I think Sports actually
raises your testosterone my coach told
me this
um I'll look
it makes a lot of sense but a lot of us
end up single because we're around these
athletes which have like a higher sexual
market value than us so that's who we
want right the guys on this level but
we're not a lot of us we're not on this
level we're competing with all the girls
that aren't don't struggle with
femininity hence a lot of us end up in
the Fun Zone um okay
next type of woman that woman that I see
is the girl that's just trying to do
better
the girls are usually
when I when I talk to them about
and I'm still guys just you know this is
like a loose
theory that I have I haven't finalized
it so there's nuance and I'm gonna make
more of these but these girls
they're like average looking white girls
usually slightly like cute pretty
um nice enough but when you bring in the
The Red Pill Concepts and talk about
modern women they always want to say oh
not all women and it's because
they don't want to make it seem like
it's them even though they know it's
them because a lot of them will have
boyfriends and a look on their Instagram
nowhere to be found what's there their
ass
their ass
wha where's the boyfriend
where's the boyfriend Diane
then okay this is the final and last one
that I can think of right now there's
more though
the the girls that read the book why men
love [ __ ] now these girls
are slightly Haven slightly just
slightly it's not like the the girls
looking to do better they don't hate men
they're just trying to do better
these girls
are the ones that men look at and
they're usually pretty but men think too
much of a headache
that that's because typically they're
charging a high price for low value a
lot of these girls either had no dad in
the home
or a weak father figure
and they typically think they're better
than what they are and they typically
want a man that like doesn't exist
so they have and they're the type that
say raise your standards raise your
standards don't accept this this this
this without ever talking about what
they bring to the table
um
um
trying to think of what else I could say
like this is one of the most common
archetypes
these girls you could tell they slept
around when they were younger
them realized it went South for them but
instead of coming back into the dating
game with a sense of humility they'll
say things like oh I had to cut
everybody off
I'm healing I healed
but instead of and this is the thing
like
coming back into the dating game with
some humility they think they're better
than everybody else
they'll try to shame women and be like I
don't want to say shame women because I
am for bringing back shame but
um they'll try to act like they're
better than certain women when they're
really not
on the same [ __ ] we can all tell because
of how jaded you are it's very obvious
it's like a sign on your forehead
um and there are also for women
empowerment a lot of these girls may say
they're conservative
they may say that and they might be I
don't know but
they're really not because of the way
they look at men it's very liberal a lot
of these girls are pro-choice they might
be conservative everything else with
their approaches it's kind of like
but Tommy Lawrence a little bit of the
world like pretty girls men need to step
up men need to do this
um I I know I'm not articulating these
perfectly but these are just some of the
patterns that I've seen so
if you have another pattern that you
think is good that you like an archetype
of woman
let me know in the comments
don't forget to subscribe to the Channel
Sign up for my memberships please I want
to go to a thousand members
um
the more
members we get the better place I can
get because I can rely on that as a
reliable source of income plus guys the
channel could be demonetized at any
moment you never know with YouTube I've
even gotten the whale video got taken
down
so you know [ __ ] like that happens all
the time and they don't like the message
so subscribe like the video on your way
out and let me know what archetype you
can think of bye